нехай так ранку за 2015 руку президенту
україни Петру Порошенку вручав Михайлу
саакашвілі після не глави адміністрації
одеської області - shape фтору руки та
саакашвілі сам подаємо стільку
подати у відставку я злодюжок про дату або
вставку і путчу ти новий етап начебто у
мадонни опустіть руки і вони в тому люсі
них і банани одягаю типу звуки симони
позбутися мене кілька днів у тому
було закрито перший в Україні
центр обслуговування chrome океан такий
вид крила турик за словом та саакашвілі
цеповяза нас прийняттям нового закону та
перекриваючи джерело фінансування
встановлений а за кілька ось індивід
ставкою саакашвілі прийшов врятував від і
начальник головного управління
національної поліції України в одеській
області
гіорги лорткіпанідзе у нас виді куба
скронь та оптимізації ми чулося без
рукавиць добу в особливо можу складу на
сьогодні не до комплектування полетіть
гайку на тисячі людей
своє рішення лордкіпанідзе ps не в
складну кадрову ситуацію виверт
українські правозахисники ген захар
поважний вигляд ставка лордкіпанідзе не
спливли на процес реформування nuts
поліції україни а сам за 1 eded друга
хвиля змін у структурі головне для
реформи поліції зміїної інституті не вона
конкретний заклик і національно прикусивши
політичних
бої
саакашвілі один су-100 них реформаторі
столітті проїхав і до України
інших краєм іноземці йдуть спосіб і тим самим
стало трендом за його в інтерв'ю д.в.
аналітика не мати котове листя за
зовнішньої політикою Степан Майстер ситуація
саакашвілі менше не було забрано ви
часом а бояри скоттом і не був не був
відразу популярну європейському союзі у
його були успіхи в одесі велю довжина
поза запуском ти процес однак його спосіб
комунікації його спосіб руб цієї
політику їжу ж консультативним вина
нашу до та компромісу видів відривав їх
підходимо ми чому ще ви назвете в на
виходьте проводьте реформи в Україні за
кутом остигли в це не політики
саакашвілі
але і популярним у Європі штефан майстер
також поважаю що в українській системі
як люди не злий не
і йому будемо hq досягнутий ще вище і
посади експорту в Україні вмовляв і
та ще до саакашвілі прем'єр-міністром
обидва що бен від йшов пар гірський процес
йшов фінансовому секторі
однак на коня європейські експерти
українські політики на і дрібниці
тюмені додаватися що у саакашвілі
сильно шлюбу я